حسنًا ، شكرًا جزيلاً ، إنه لشرف كبير
أن أكون
مع ملك الأردن الذي كان
شريكًا لنا وحليفًا لفترة طويلة
وأعتقد أن العلاقة لم تكن أبدًا
أفضل مما هي عليه الآن
ونحن نعمل معًا لحل العديد من
المشاكل  وبعض الأشياء التي لا تمثل
مشاكل جيدة جدًا
ولكننا سنجعل بعض الأشياء السيئة تبدو
جيدة
لذا أود أن أشكرك وأريد أن
أشكر كل من شارك معك
وقمت بعمل رائع
شكرا لك شكرا لك
السيد الرئيس شكرا جزيلا
لاستضافتنا هنا
ومرة أخرى تعلم أننا التقينا عدة مر
ت هذا العام وأعتقد أن هذا يظهر فقط عل
قة خاصة بين بل
ينا ويقدم تعازينا في
حايا  الأعاصير ولكن أيضًا
كيف تفاعلت الحكومة مع الأشخاص
المستجيبين الأوائل
لهذه الأزمة ، أعني بالنسبة لنا أن نجلس في
الخارج وننظر في كيفية اجتماع الأمريكيين
معًا في وقت صعب هو حقًا
مثال للجميع و  نحن
ممتنون جدًا لذلك
وكل ما نقوم به
لمحاولة حل مشاكلنا لدينا مشكلة كبيرة
تجري
الآن لم أرَ رياحًا كهذه في
بورتوريكو ، ألقي نظرة على ما
يحدث هناك واه
فقط واحدًا تلو الآخر ، لكني أعتقد
أننا نقوم بعمل جيد ، يجب أن أقول هذا
عن الملك ،
إنه رجل نبيل رائع جدًا ، رجل لطيف للغاية ،
إنه أيضًا مقاتل رائع ،
لذا يجب على الناس أن يفهموا أنه صحيح
أيضًا أننا جميعًا نقاتل معًا
أعني أن الإرهاب بلاء في
جميع أنحاء العالم ، لكنني أعتقد أن
الأردن سيقف إلى جانبك دائمًا وبجانب
بلدك وسنتغلب على الخير.